[Music]
Cheeto look not everyone was good at
biology you want to play me in a science
quiz yeah absolutely I'm very good at
biology I have a four-year degree in it
enter animal oh iguana we're going to
water the first one okay guys and there
we go maybe a little bit more that's too
much no it didn't drown the plant what
is that a
buffalo the asteroid took out all the
dinosaurs yeah but like that doesn't
make sense it just took them out like a
perfect like perfect hit like where's
every
else
[Music]
crocodiles sometimes you just get
confused about
like like how many legs do chicken have
they actually only have two chicken can
watermelon grow in the sky or like how
they
[Music]
grow that a chicken